[Musique]
oser un
mythe on m'avait dit euh tu verras c'est
cool c'est comme le Jamel Comedy
Club c'est un peu ça un peu il y a du
vrai c'est vrai qu'il y a des comiques
dans la salle mais là-bas en tout cas il
y en a un sur la
scène
rosé Michel odudiar a pendu cette
réplique superbe les con ça ose tout
c'est même à ça qu'on les
reconnaît vous comprenez maintenant
pourquoi j'ai un petit peu hésité
lorsqu'on m'a proposé de passer ici ce
soir bon à la décharche des
organisateurs ils ont eu le bon goût de
faire ça un jeudi un jeudi et pas un
mercredi soir ça vous ça vous évitera de
d'écouter mes histoires de
d'allumette j'aurais pu vous entretenir
de l'audace qu'il y a à aller au soleil
sans crème solaire ou bien du courage
qu'il faut pour aller dans manger dans
certaines
gargotes mais j'ai j'ai choisi non pas
de vous faire une leçon
magistrale mais tenter de vous expliquer
pourquoi oser dans ma tête ressortait du
myth pour préparer ce ce petit exposé je
suis aller visionner quelques
prestations sur la toile mais j'ai
commencé par essayer de comprendre ce
que signifiait
oser il y a plein de synonymes à oser
s'armer de courage s'aventurer s'aviser
deavoir du cœur au ventre avoir du
courage avoir de l'audace enfin plein de
trucs et j ai fait quelques découvertes
mais on y reviendra plus tard posons
tout d'abord le socle ou plutôt les
fondamentaux je suis né dans une famille
de six enfants dont je suis le
second j'étais un solide bébé de 4, 800
à la
naissance pas vraiment rachitique je
veux pas entendre
déjà la nature m'a donc donné une
constitution
robuste un esprit que parfois je crois
vif mais à maturation extrêmement lente
je crois qu'il y a pas mon esprit
seulement mon esprit qui était qui était
à maturation
lente à 17 ans j'avais le développement
physique d'un garçon de 12 ans et demi
on fait
mieux en même temps j'avais des petits
airs boiset comme ça j'avais toujours la
bouche ouverte je savais pas respirer
donc j'allais chez le docteur pour faire
de la physio et puis finalement on a
décidé de m'opérer des végétations puis
des amidales donc voyez le
résultat durant mon enfance j'ai aussi
fait l'apprentissage assez précoce du du
travail on était beaucoup d'enfants dans
un milieu relativement modeste et je
contribuais mais très très modestement
au dépense du du ménage euh en vendant
des cartes de nouvelles en allant porter
des journaux enensemble plein de trucs
comme ça et pour mon argent de poêe
personnel j'avais un truc fantastique
j'allais traer des traer des
taupes 15 centimes la queue de taupe
j'aimais bien l'école j'apprenais assez
facilement et ma scolarité assez
sommaire se déroulé
facilement euh vous connaissez tous le
film Tangui je pense voilà ben là on m'a
fait comprendre que tangil était pas né
et il fallait que je dégage assez vite
de la maison à 16 ans je suis parti de
la maison j'ai donc pris une chambre et
pour la payer ben j'allais travailler le
samedi chez un chez un
boulanger
c'était une enfance pas pas la Zola je
parle d'em000 pas de Gorgon mais il y
avait
is elle était assez rude mais il y avait
quand même des traits de lumière c'est
quand j'allais à la montagne avec mon
père le weekend pour des des longues
randonnées parfois des très très longes
randonné et il y a quand même des points
positifs à tout ça c'est que j'ai appris
très très tôt à à
m'assumé à 15 ans à la fin de l'école
secondaire j'ai choisi de faire un
apprentissage labour en chimie enfin
quand je dis choisis je raconte presque
un mensonge parce que on avait vu une
petite annonce dans la gruillère il
cherchait des candidats à une place
d'apprentissage de labour en chimie il y
avait plein de candidats on avait
l'occasion d'aller faire une semaine de
stage là-bas et au terme du stage il y
avait 12 élus j'étais assez flatté de
faire partie de ces élus et puis je suis
devenu laborant chimie il y a des
hasards qui font bien les choses j'ai
travaillé ensuite comme laborant en
chimie pendant 4 5 ans dans le domaine
de la cosmétique capillaire vous voyez
le résult
et ensuite j'ai eu des postes
responsable de la boî dans le domaine de
l'emballage ou de la la cosmétique de
luxe vers ouais après 30 ans à 33
ans poussé par la curiosité mais aussi
l'aspiration à meilleur condition
pécunière et de gestion de mon temps je
suis devenu délégué médical alors g
médical à l'époque c'était un job
fantastique on se promenait en voiture
on allait trouver des gens surtout des
docteurs on rasait on rasait les murs au
au
début et puis on leur racontait ce qu'on
avait à leur raconter et puis on
espérait que les ventes résultent de
notre travail et ça marchait pas
mal j'ai travaillé d'abord dans le
domaine de la nutrition infantile c'est
à l'époque où on savait pas encore que
le les énel c'est le meilleur la
meilleure nourriture pour les enfants
maintenant je crois qu'on a on a compris
ensuite j'ai travaillé en nutrition
clinique la nutrition clinique c'était
un domaine fantastique passionnant
malheureusement ce qui est bon n'est pas
forcément
bon et inversément alors ce qui a bon
goût c'est pas forcément bon pour la
santé et ce qui est bon pour la santé
n'a pas forcément bon goût donc
finalement c'est des domaines un petit
peu frustrants et petit à petit je me
suis orienté vers l'ophtalmologie plus
précisément vers le la chirurgie
ophtalmique et là je crois que j'ai
vraiment trouvé ma voix j'étais déjà
plus tout neuf mais c'était un domaine
assez sympa alors chirurgie ophtalmique
c'était
essentiellement cataracte c'était glaucô
c'était chirurgie de correction de
laavux aussi et c'est là que en fait
j'ai pu assouvir une de mes
aspirations une aspiration
d'indépendance et j'ai eu l'occasion de
créer un centre de chirurgie réfractive
et cette expérience elle a elle a duré
10 ans elle éta enrichissante à à pas
mal d'égards mais surtout il y avait la
haute technologie il y avait beaucoup de
rapport humains et on travaillait dans
une émotion c'est fantastique de voir
quelqu'un qui sort du centre et puis qui
a recouvrit une meilleure vue c'est très
très
gratifiant mon chemin professionnel a
été certes tortueux mais toujours guidé
par des envies de connaissance de vie
meilleure et peut-être aussi
d'ambition mais aussi par des rêves qui
n'en viiennent comme vous le savez plus
dès qu'ils sont
réalisés ils ont aussi été guidés par le
choix de s'extraire d'un destin a priori
moins favorable
et osé dans tout
ça je me suis
hasardé lorsque j'ai choisi une
profession parce que franchement c'était
200 % de hasard je me suis enhardi
lorsque j'ai changer de profession parce
que j'avais je sais pas 30 33 ans 33 ans
bon j'étais PP j'avais le temps de
courir c'était super mais
ok il faut bouger et puis lorsqu'on a
créé et le centre là il faut y aller
avec les tripes et si je vous parlais de
mon itinéraire de
sportif rassurez-vous je vais pas vous
parler de
golf je vous ai tout à l'heure que les
rayons de soleil de mon enfance c'était
les balades en montagne avec mon père
pendant ces balades qui pouvaient durer
assez longtemps 10 12h ça dépendait mon
père il avait une P technique pour me
faire passer le temps il me parlait
beaucoup de cyclisme de montagne de ce
qu' font parlait de coblette de Kubler
de bartalit copie de rebuffa de
garyeming enfin c'était tous des c'est
devenu mes mes héros des mecs que
j'admirais dont j'allais euh lire des
livres c'était des quelque part des des
modèles ces balades ont laissé des
traces ord physique che à qui une bonne
endurance mais aussi mentale on a
l'habitude de se promener
pendant
longtemps au bout d'un moment on se
plaint plus tellement il y a son père
qui nous prend la main on est tout de
suite beaucoup plus
fort mais ça m'a aussi donné pas mal
confiance en moi ça m'a aussi permis
d'avoir mes propres rêves et si on y
ajoute une bonne
que j'avais acquise pendant mon enfance
bah on arrive à tout ce qu'il faut pour
faire un sportif
d'endurance à 14 ans après avoir fait du
F et puis constater que mes pieds il
étaient assez carré et plus j'avais pas
la mesure comme vous le savez les petits
poissons on les remet à l'eau donc pas
assz bon pour faire du
f j'ai décidé de faire de la course à
pied et assez rapidement je suis devenu
un bon un bon courur
régional mais là où tout ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure au sujet de la
maturation ça prend son sens c'est qu'il
m'a fallu à peu près 15 ans pour
comprendre que je serai jamais un
coureur de demifond j'étais pas assez
vite je seraai jamais un super coureur
de 5000 10000 j'étais peut-être pas
assez résistant que je gardnerai jamais
Moison parce que j'étais beaucoup trop
lourd mais que j'avais des super
qualités de descendeur et que je gérais
assez bien assez bien une longue
course j'avais en plus une petite chance
c'est que
j'étais moyen à bon partout
et je me suis dit ok pourquoi tu ferait
pas euh de la la vraie course montagne
et la la reine des courses montagnes
c'était c'était czinal
là on est en
1984 je fais cinal je finis 6e et puis
là je m'aperçois vraiment qu'il a du
potentiel pour pour faire un peu mixysiè
et là je mets vraiment tout ce que j'ai
dans le dans l'estomac et dans ma
tête ce que je comprends aussi c'est que
je retourne en 88 et j'arrive
effectivement à la gagner pour la
première
fois maintenant qu'est-ce c'était la
recette la recette c'était
l'entraînement la patience et surtout la
foi et quelle est la place du verbe oser
dans tout ce
processus c'est difficile de répondre à
à cette question puisque le choix de
courir c'est c'est fait d'abord par
défaut j' Tai j'éis trop mauvais en
fouette
pour pour espérer quoi que ce soit
ensuite j'ai compris que la course à
pied c'était c'était beaucoup de liberté
il y a personne qui allait m'embêter me
dire fais C fais ça et cetera j'ai
toujours été un peu
réfractif au Conseil des
entraîneurs et puis ensuite j'avais
probablement envie d'accomplir quelque
chose au confin de mes possibilités
essayer d'être à 100 % quelque part et
c'était probablement un domaine où où
c'était possible de de le faire et j'ai
eu le front ou le tpai de penser que je
pouvais être le meilleur dans une
activité sportive ça peut-être que ça
ressemble à
oser d'autre part j'ai vraiment mis mon
cerveau au service de mes buts et pas de
mes
peurs public chéri je vous dois vraiment
à tous la
vérité j'ai eu l'audace au moins une
fois dans ma vie à 5 51 ans j'ai fait la
connaissance d'une jeune femme de 23 ans
ma cadette ça veut dire on était pas
vraiment
euh culture complètement
différente milieu complètement différent
éducation complètement
différente c'était un peu l'histoire de
la belle et
laabête et j'ai osé dire oui à sa
demandeant
mariage bon là ça compte pas bien parce
que c'était purement
émotionnel au travers ces trois
chapitres de ma vie vous pourrez
peut-être comprendre que même si l'
retient ses pantalons avec une ceinture
avec des bretelles et puis une main dans
les
poches il est parfois nécessaire de
prendre des des décisions dooser quel
que soit le mot qu'on utilise quel que
soit le terme qu'on
utilise à condition d'y mettre la
réflexion la plus aigue et l'énergie
d'un
mort de fin moi j'appelle ça du
pragmatisme merci
beaucoup